[Music]
william nicholson first worked as a
documentary filmmaker at the bbc before
becoming a writer subsequently combining
novels children's books plays and
screenplays
his feature scripts range from action
adventures like gladiator first night
and elizabeth the golden age to
emotional human dramas such as nell and
firelight which he also directed
to date he has received three bafta
nominations it is with great pleasure
that we welcome william nicholson to the
bafta and bfi screenwriters lecture
series
[Music]
screenwriters
do not write
dialogue
this is a misunderstanding
people often say which lines did you
write
of course we do write dialogue but
that's not the big thing we write we
write
story
we create stories
we've as screenwriters colluded in a
system that treats the writing of the
script as a disposable element that you
can get in a writer sakurai to get in
another writer that the script is
probably done by many hands probably by
the director as well so anyway who knows
who created it that's the view
you can have an entire movie without a
single line of dialogue and every moment
has been written by a screenwriter
the screenwriter imagines what's going
to happen puts it on paper and some
minor
functionary called a director comes and
actually makes it happen
we write what you see it's all there in
paper here in britain it's not our
system here we have a much greater
respect for writers and actually most
films where you'll see a writer credit
that writer did actually write that film
so i think we can start doing something
here
to make people aware of writers we've
got a chance of rescuing the film
process from this degradation which of
course produces the crap movies that we
have so many of
[Music]
if you are somebody who wants to be a
screenwriter and you're not breaking
through and you're having to work at
something else
rejoice in that you will be astounded
down the line you'll be writing a
screenplay about that burger bar that
you've been working in or whatever it is
if all you've ever done is watched
movies the only movies you can write are
movies that recycle the contents of
other movies
and god knows there's enough of them
but we don't want that we want reality
we want truth that's where the power
lies so what is it that makes movies
really great i'll tell you in three
steps
the first step is the structure
the structure of a story let's call it a
story has got to mirror the reality that
the audience is familiar with
very very important this
if you have a series of random events
that don't seem to connect what people
do don't fall that doesn't follow on
from anything they've done before
it throws you out of the story you kind
of don't feel involved what happens as
you watch a story is you feel yes if
somebody acted like that the following
would follow and that yes that's true
that's right that matches my sense of
reality so the overall structure
has got to relate to our lived
experience
of
the world that we all share
well his his writing has always been
very um personally influential to me
because i started off in television and
i remember vividly seeing
um a life story which was one of the
first dramatic works that he wrote and
it was one of those examples of just
something that was breathtakingly more
than you would ever imagine you could
see
when you just switch on the television
it it was a drama based on the life of
rosie franklin and watson and crick who
discovered dna and
it
did the most unlikely thing it took a
scientific discovery made it
comprehensible to everyone in a dramatic
form
littered with intelligence great
characterization emotion tension and at
the end of the 90 minutes you were
watching
a molecule a dna structure and you
understood how they had arrived at that
discovery
and it all made sense i create a
structure and i try and get it on a
single piece of paper so that i can see
the whole thing see the the the whole
thing about writing not just
screenwriting is you have to be micro
and you have to macro all at the same
time
you must find your place in your overall
scheme at every moment but at the same
time when you go into the micro that's
got to exist on its own terms with great
energy and i think a lot of people lose
the macro as they go along second thing
you've got to do you've got to have
characters that we actually recognize
and this is very important because if
you recognize the characters as being
true people you can care about them and
as step number two in what makes a great
movie in my opinion it is
caring about the characters particularly
about the central character think of how
many movies you've seen where you know
it was kind of great
but you didn't care
you were never ever engaged by the
plight or the longings of the central
character that is dead in the water
think of other movies you've seen where
they probably didn't make a lot of sense
and were a bit of a mess but you really
love that central person then they're
going to work even if even if they're
messy
[Music]
i'm not sure i do feel i have a voice to
offer i wish i could offer the voice i
don't think anybody wants my voice in
films to be honest with you what i think
i can
increasingly offer as my career has gone
along
is
an insight
into what happens between people when
they hurt each other and love each other
and so forth and i've kind of
specialized in that
and so when i get to work on a film i'll
usually deepen a character and make
their responses more truthful that's
what i'm trying to do anyway
i find that
most films i write
fall into sections i don't like to call
them acts because there's often more
than three and they're bigger than beats
but there are sections this happens then
this happens then this happens this
happens i don't do them on index cards
and shuffle them around um i rewrite the
page if necessary but yes it's there so
i
it there's a lot of pacing involved in
in writing a film
you need to know you're going quiet
things are going gentle something is
building what is the audience being led
to expect what are they wanting at this
point what don't they know what do they
want to know when am i going to tell
them
when there's a big change have i
surprised them enough with that and i
need to know when that change happens so
that i'm building to it caring
about characters
generates the third step in the process
which is what in my opinion is the
gold
of movie making
which is emotion
we are in the business of generating
emotion
that's why people go to the cinema they
want to be frightened they want to be
thrilled they want to be filled with
wonder they want to laugh
they want to cry i don't believe you can
generate decent emotion without
true characters in a true story
what about some of their long-promised
tea yes please
you take milk don't you
yes
no i uh i'd be interested to know about
your bones
what what do you want to know about them
how long they are
their rhyme schemes their major
influences
of course you take sugar
sure
quite fine
uh
well would you be so kind as to
introduce me
to the poems themselves
most films that posit a love affair fail
in my opinion they assert it they show
you a close-up of a beautiful woman and
a close-up of a beautiful man and they
play the kind of music that makes out
that they're loving each other and they
try to persuade you look it's happening
i don't think that is enough
in shadowlands i had a middle-aged don a
crusty bachelor don
very defended and i had a divorced
jewish woman who's a fan of his who's
read all his works who's not exactly
stalking him but he's clearly interested
in him i didn't know anything else i
didn't know what happened between them
how the sparks flew and i had to create
a scene in which what you actually
witness happening is the guy
waking up
to the possibility that there's
something in this woman that's special
pain is a tool
if you like pain is god's message
megaphone to rouse a deaf world
oh how embarrassing
you know my writing too well don't you i
have read most of it
i guess i knew you pretty well before we
met
ah
but you've not had the personal
experience
mr lewis i
i have to stop calling you mr lewis it
makes me feel like a kid
can i call you jack
yes of course
jack i'm joy
oh hello joy
so jack
have you ever been really hurt
you don't give up you
i always do know when i begin a
screenplay where it's going to end
myself not everybody does
i find that very valuable so a little
moment like that is actually part of a
journey about pain and the the value of
pain
what i have
discovered over the years is that i
don't start writing until i have my
ending
i always structure the story
in other words i sit down and say to
myself
here is the situation i'm asked to write
about how can i turn it into a story
who is the main character what does the
main character want what are the
obstacles in the way and how is it going
to resolve and all of that
i know the answer to before i start
writing um
quite often i'll also say to myself
what are the great moments
in this story and
where are they going to be happening and
what is the key emotion that's going to
happen in them
so you know if you're writing a love
story you obviously have the moment when
they meet is crucial the moment when
they
after having met they discover that
there's something happening between them
that's more than uh just a normal
meeting
um then there's going to be
things are going to go wrong and then
eventually they're going to discover
each other and they're going to get
together if you're telling that kind of
story and you've got to track each of
these moments and say how am i going to
deliver these and how am i going to make
the audience believe this i am going to
advise you very strongly at the end of
this talk to become a writer director if
you want to be a writer
i have done it and this puts me in a
good position to say two things
being a director is easier than you
think i was always in awe of directors
rightly by the way i mean you know the
many directors are geniuses however
quite a few directors
are completely hopeless and you really
could have made the whole film without
them present in fact i've been on one
film where the director might as well
have just stayed away
um you can make a film as a director
because you get an amazing team around
you you get a cinematographer who knows
what he's doing you get a designer who
knows what he's doing you get a first
assistant who knows what he's doing all
they want from you is to know what
results to produce
and if you're a writer you know that so
don't be frightened of directing
i loved it
i want you
i can help her
i know i can
but first she has to be taught to obey
me
if you harm so much as one hair on her
head
do you think i of all people would ever
had her
i make you a promise
whatever i do to resilient to myself
you want her to love you
i want her to be loved
there you have my entire theory of
parenting you want her to love you i
want her to be loved
um and that ties in with what i was
saying right at the beginning about
being an author being having authority
you know there's going to come a point
in the stuff you write where you've got
to write something that's actually of
some value and how do you get that value
you get it through living
so it actually you know you can't just
spend your entire time writing you've
got to get out there and learn and live
and have experiences and have
relationships and process them all um
through your your screenwriting
how do you learn to do that you don't
learn to do it by going to screenwriting
school you learn to do it by screwing up
your own love life a great deal by
talking to people by knowing about the
pain there is in the world by living
through it yourself i mean i've not
lived through an enormous amount of pain
i in a sense i've never been to war for
example i wish i had if i had
like tolstoy went to war and god he
could write about war you know so i i
think this does
really emphasize what i want to say is
that your greatness is a as a writer is
your greatness as a human being
i think he is one of the masters on
faith romance and responsibility and
that doesn't he can do that in a small
and contained world
or he can do it in an epic and mythic
world but he brings um
he brings a real understanding of
character and humanity and emotion which
is um singular and intelligent to the
screen
i don't think in terms of themes but
when i look back on my work i observe
that there are
which is interesting to me um a lot of
my
works have been set in the past um
that's partly an accident i don't adapt
books so people tend to come up with
existing stories in the real world for
me to turn into to movies
i don't adapt books because somebody
else has had all the fun of creating the
characters and that's what i like
whereas when you're taking the real
world historically you have to create
characters out of that
um but when i look at the all the things
i've done
two things keep recurring one is
religious themes god after life
and
it's obviously something that's very
deep in me and uh and i i'm
fascinated by anything to do that i'm
not a believer myself but i'm obviously
somebody who wants to play around in
that sandpit um the other one is
love of course
love and sex
i would add to that parenting love sex
kids and
i've put a lot of that into the films
that i have
done and it's clearly
something that obsesses me and it keeps
on popping up i mean i've even got both
those themes into gladiator which is
extraordinary they were two weeks off
shooting i was
asked initially simply to solve the
problem of making russell crowe more
attractive character because as you
gather character is my thing character
and emotion
what i said was this is a fantastic
project
um but i don't like maximus and i don't
like him because he's a killer and i
don't like killers now probably a lot of
people do like killers but i don't in
fact i like
men who love their wives and children
because that's me
so why don't we make this big butch
tough general a guy who wants to be a
farmer doesn't want to be a soldier
loves his wife and children
now there's one slight wrinkle here
which is that his wife and child are
going to die and that was in the plot i
couldn't change that so i said no
problem we will have an afterlife and
we're going to make this guy
go through this entire film to get to
his wife he's not going through this
entire film to kill the bad guy he's
going through it to to do something
loving
and that
decision alone i believe doubled the
receipts of that film because it meant
women liked the film
women went to the film because here was
a hero who is dead butch and can protect
you against baddies but he's tender and
a family man caring about characters
does not just apply to your hero it
applies to your body as well i believe
that a baddie who you feel you
understand why they're a baddie is a
better baddie you're more interested
you're more engaged you believe the
baddie more so my task was to make
commodus somebody you could relate to
and uh the scene as it arrived to me
consisted of commodore sitting by the
bed on which his father marcus aurelius
richard harris is lying and he's
speaking about um uh about his father
and he's kind of moaning you know about
how his father doesn't love him and then
you realize his father's dead and you
guess
that he has killed him
my reaction to this is that is not the
train crash i want to see the train
crash i want to see him kill his father
so i rewrote the scene
bring his father back to life i want to
actually see that interaction between
them i wrote some speeches in which
commodus attempts to explain himself to
his father and basically to the audience
so that even though he's still a bad guy
you think you know what i can kind of
understand where he's coming from
in his desire for his father to love him
which is the emotional engine of the
scene
that that desire for his father to love
him would become the energy with which
he murders his father in other words he
would hug him to death
father
commodus
your false as a son
is my failure
as a father
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
i would put to the whole world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i suppose
in a way i think the thing that's most
interesting about the way he he works is
the way he takes characters and he take
he provides characters with an
intelligence and a privacy and an
interior life and an exterior life that
they
they play out on screen for you so that
you you
see their imagination and you witness
their imagination when i'm asked to
write a film
um you know like elizabeth the golden
age
elizabeth is the center of this film
what is her situation her situation is
that she is a queen and therefore she
can't marry because if you marry a man
the man is your superior your husband
can control you unacceptable for a queen
she can't marry she can't have children
so what does she do about love
dilemma number one
how does she solve that this is me
making this up she says
what i'm gonna do is my beloved um
uh lady in waiting this young girl bess
she will deal with the part i can't give
to the man i love so basically he can
have sex with bess can't have sex with
me but he loves me and i love bess that
i found extremely interesting to put
my main character in this situation
because you just know when you see that
starting it ain't going to work now why
is it not going to work not because she
says oh i hear you've been sleeping with
bear so
i'm not going to have any of that she's
the queen she's bigger than that
but the thing that blows her apart is
when bess gets pregnant
and suddenly
she's confronted with the physical
reality of the things she will never
have a baby all of that comes out of
saying
what's it like to be elizabeth an entire
story comes out of that now there's a
another story to do with a battle
which has to be woven into that but
that's what interested me and i built it
around character
okay i'd like to give your son my
blessing
i'd be on it
hmm
[Applause]
this is her act of reconciliation to
hold the baby
uh rally's baby bess's baby in her arms
and what i then faced was the idea of
how do i indicate what she's feeling at
the end and what i opted for and the
production accepted was a piece of voice
over which is you know widely known as
director's mistake when you have to
voice everyone but this was planned
i think it works really powerfully
because i wanted to take the whole
emotional
where i wound it so tight take it to the
next level
i am called the virgin queen
unmarried
i have no master
childless
i am mother to my people
god give me strength to bear this mighty
freedom
i am your queen
i've had a very uneven experience some
of it's been good a lot of it's been bad
but you get paid a lot
and that then becomes the continuing
motivation to continue um in the big
film world plus to be fair it's
thrilling to be involved in a film that
goes around the world that everybody
sees that everybody talks about that
influences the culture that that is
thrilling quite rare um i've had a
little bit of a share of some of that
and and i'm i'm very grateful for that
but you know
it's not a world to lock yourself into
it's a world to go into and enjoy
and then have another world also to go
into to keep you sane
if you want to be a screenwriter i'm
going to say that you need three things
you need talent obviously and by the way
talent can be learned i truly believe
that what is talent i think it's
as a screenwriter you have to be this
fountain of ideas all the time it's
you've got to be confident you need
self-confidence
tempered by self-criticism that's my
little kind of summary of it if you
don't criticize your work and you don't
let other people criticize it you will
go to hell if you have no confidence
you'll produce nothing discipline if you
haven't got discipline forget it this is
not a game that you do like an essay at
university where you stay up all night
on black coffee at the last minute i
know maybe some people do i don't
believe it you do it every day you do it
systematically you don't let yourself
stop
you make yourself right even when you
don't want to write you make yourself
right even when people have criticized
you and you feel like hell the third
thing is you are going to have to have a
very particular kind of temperament
this is because
the life of a screenwriter is
unmitigated hell
now you may not have picked this up from
what i've said so far but it really
really is
everything you write will be ripped to
pieces by other people who are not fools
it'll be easy if they were fools you
could despise them they're not they're
smart people every time they rip your
script apart you think why didn't i see
that it's so obvious you feel like you
are nothing at the end of every session
with notes and you've somehow got to
drag yourself up again and go back to
work and you have to do that repeatedly
and after you've done it draft after
draft
blow me in comes a director who seems to
think that the script is an early sketch
that he can do what he likes with
and then along come actors who say oh no
i think we'll do something different so
you cannot
be a shrinking violet
with a passionate sense of your own
voice they don't want your voice they
don't want you
they just want a job done the minute you
click send and your script goes off to
the production team whatever stage put
it out of your mind start something else
that's the only way you will actually
not go insane
in this strange business
[Music]
we writers
are so fortunate because we live our
lives twice we live it through our
experience then we live it through the
reflection on that experience that comes
through our writing which then deepens
our subsequent experience so we are the
people who are going through this life
awake
and we're surrounded by people in a sort
of trance state but luckily they're the
people who pay the money to go to the
cinema
[Music]
you